alright so I'm a student with the
overall ER I want to thank Martin for
giving me the chance to speak today
alright so that the project I'm going to
talk about today is basically a
collaboration with this corner of the
slide so the estimates only lab at New
York University and sean mahoney lab at
penn state and really the main person
who's been working on this for two or
three years was Sylvia could you saw the
date I'm going to talk about so the
system we're using is this direct
programming we have pluripotent cells
that we start with and it's an inducible
cell line so we add doxycycline and we
induce the expression of these three
transcription factors and after 48 hours
we get a homogeneous population of motor
neurons of spinal motor neurons that are
actually functional and yeah and
homogeneous so the question we wanted to
ask is why is it that these three
factors are successful in doing this
because this is a very short time span
and because we have a success rate
almost more than ninety percent of the
cells turn into spinal motor neurons so
why is it that these factors can do it
and so we did a time-course experiment
with RNA seek chip seek for different
histone modifications and of course for
these three factors it's Mouse so the
starting point just so that everybody
knows we have info report and stem cells
we have these bivalent promoters that
have both h3k4 trimethylation EK 27 tri
methyl so you have both active and
inactive histone modifications on the
promoter and the idea is that these
genes are poised or are ready to either
to become activated
and these are typically the
developmental genes if you actually take
in stem cells all these genes that have
h3k4 trimethylation of acid h3k27 and
settle to h3k27me3 you get this nice
bimodal distribution and if you do if
you plug gene expression for these
things and if you do general regiment
you find that these are the
developmental genes that are really
bivalent and that these are the the
other genes that are actually expressed
in stem cells and so what must happen
during stem cell differentiation is that
these two populations will shift right
so some of these genes will become
deactivated and some of these genes will
become activated and that and that this
will have to be resolved somehow so we
did chip seek for these three marks
h3k27 and settle h3k27 trimethylation 3k
for tri methyl over the time course of
this district differentiation to try to
understand how this process is working
so we have three histone modifications
we have many genes and we have different
time points so we want to Co cluster
these different histone modifications
across time and we don't know how this
is going to look like so we wanted a
very general framework where we can just
do this clustering and just look at the
data how it looks like so it's very
simple the thing we came up with
basically you have something like a
Markov chain or actually it could be a
tree you can in our case it's a linear
progression because our system is linear
but if you can imagine you have
something that has branching like blood
development or something like that you
could also have a more complicated tree
and basically there is a so these things
you observe this is your data and
basically you have the class that then
determines our
your data looks like so this is it this
is a tree augmented naive basement
except that we don't observe this and we
fit this with an e em algorithm the main
trick is that this is not really the
data but the change in the data so this
if we have a zero zero hours this is
going to be the full change from zero
hours to 12 hours this is the full
change from 24 to 12 hours and this is
the full change from 48 to 24 hours so
this in a way becomes more like a like
second order train maybe and and this is
nice because they are when you do the
full change they look Gaussian but the
data doesn't look I've seen so this is
very good at catching trends and you can
basically have this model this of course
describes only one histone modification
you could have a multivariate
distribution here to add the histone
modifications the other ones but
actually what we did is we added so for
each new histone modification or its new
data that you have you can add another
chain just like this so we have three we
have three of these chains all linked to
this promoter class and that's how we do
it so if we run this model on the data
that we had on the system i just
described we get we get 11 clusters I'm
showing you the the nicest three here so
the first one you see that at zero hours
you had a high h3k4 trimethylation BK 27
tri methyl and low acetylation which
corresponds to this bivalent genes that
a lot of people characterize and you see
that during the differentiation a switch
happens and you get higher acetylation
than methylation at the end and this
corresponds to a very clear increase in
gene expression on the other hand you
get the other opposite side of the coin
in a way where you have things that
start high in a set elation and low in
k-27 tri methyl and this the opposite
switch happens
and you get a corresponding decrease in
gene expression and if you actually do
pathway enrichment or go enrichment you
find that these are motor neuron
differentiation genes which makes sense
because you're differentiating motor
neurons and these are the pluripotency
and cell cycle jeans on the other hand
there are genes that start out like this
so they have again this is by valent
promoter type thing and basically
nothing happens to them over time and
their expression remains low over time
and these are actually the other
developmental genes that are not
relevant to our to our motor neuron fate
so those jeans do not get resolved yeah
maybe they get resolved later if we kept
the neurons going later we don't know
but yeah but as far as we went with 48
hours they do not get resolved yeah so
this is very good so we have these
different dynamics if you actually look
at a more complete picture at all though
there were 11 clusters we have four
clusters that show a little bit that
show like upregulation and we have three
that shows some down regulation we have
other this four and three is seven so we
have four clusters that basically stay
constant either low or repressed or
active so I'm not showing those here and
basically what you see is that we have
actually different types of activation
so not everything looks like the cluster
I showed you on the previous slide we
have different trajectories of
activation and also not everything looks
like this one here we have different
trajectories also of repression and this
corresponds to the strength or the order
or the dynamics of gene activation so
these are scaled this is the same data
that's followed here the gene expression
data is just scaled for every gene so
that it highlights better the dynamics
and you can sort of see that this is the
strongest activation this is a little
bit weaker weaker weaker and then you
see the switch with the other three
clusters and you start getting the
okay so this is good we have different
we have the bivalent motor neuron
differentiation genes they are activated
by the switch and the four important c
genes are repressed by the opposite
switch you have the bivalent genes that
are not related to the motor neuron
phase you stay the same and we can see
that during differentiation although our
system is homogeneous there is not one
trajectory for activation there are
multiple trajectories okay so now we
know that we this happens and we know
that we induce three factors and that in
using these three factors is what causes
this so naturally we want to ask how are
these three factors doing that and so
with the chip seek for these three
factors and we did chip seek at 12 hours
24 hours and 48 hours because of course
at zero hours they are not yet they're
not yet there so right so this is the
work from akshay for the student at
Ranma honey's lab so what he did is a
here on differential peak finding to
characterize how these factors behaved
and so eyelet and LH x32 of the factors
we induce we found that the always
pretty much bind go bind together to the
same sites while neurogenic to hear
mostly doesn't bind with eyelets and LH
x3 so you see this overlap but in most
cases there is not much overlap between
new regional and i'll attend i'll check
three so basically we have two types of
binding we have inet and electric three
binding and we have neurogenic binding i
should also mention that nirajan we only
did the chip seek for 12 hours because
later on the protein starts getting
degraded so yeah so we're jen is only
there at 12 hours right so the so this
happens so we want to ask are these
factors involved in activation only
activation of the motor neuron faith or
are they involved also in repression and
how do they do this and one of the first
questions we can ask is
they're binding static or dynamic like
do they go to sites that they want to go
to and just stay there or do they change
their sites over time so this is again
akshay's work and what he did is he ran
again differential peak finding for lhx
three sides for 12 hours versus 48 hours
and what we get so to characterize
things that are high at 12 hours and
blow at 48 hours things that are high 48
hours and low at 12 hours and things
that stay the same and since we find big
like large numbers for each group that
means that the binding of our factors is
both dynamic and Static you get these
dynamic sites and we get these static
sites where the factor goes and just
stays there right so since we know this
one of the main questions that we can
ask is ok we have the chromatin
landscape of the pluripotent cells where
we started do these factors go to sites
that were already accessible in these
pluripotent cells or do they go to sites
that we're not accessible and they open
them by themselves and so one of the
things we did is simply we did a taxi at
zero hours of this pluripotent cells and
we and we plotted the attacks accounts
at the neuro genocides suicides that are
only neurogenic and at the size that are
only a letter L checks three and what we
can see surprisingly is that near jenin
actually likes to bind more open things
than I love and I'll check three we can
quantify this by pig finding so if you
do Pig finding in this ataxic data set
and intersect the transcription factors
with the attack seek peaks but we can
see is that nirajan and at 12 hours
about thirty-eight percent of it bind
sites that were already accessible in in
the zero hours the early only so these
sides here early only a latex3 and
eyelet sides about twenty-six percent of
them buying things that were accessible
the constant size these ones about ten
percent and the late sides very very few
which makes sense because they come in
late
during the differentiation so so based
on this we decided to split the first
two into two further categories things
that we're accessible in the 80 hours
and things that were not accessible at
zero hours so we have six categories
this accessibility hours and not
accessible as your hours early only
accessible and not accessible constant
and laid a conclusion in milk so we have
a genin and eyelid yeah it's primarily
independent their binding doesn't
overlap except for very few sides eyelid
binding is both dynamic and constant
neuro journal and binding and binding
happens both in accessible inaccessible
regions and so if you look at these six
groups and we plot attacks seek and
h3k27 and settle for these groups over
time while we can see is something
really nice is that when these factors
bind sites that were already accessible
at zero hours these sites get
deactivated or decommissioned or
depressed because you see a decrease so
the orange is ataxic at zero hours Black
is ataxic at motor neurons at 48 hours
you see that these sites which were near
jenin newtonian size that were
accessible they go down a little bit and
also in the escalation to compare the
orange to the black curve they will go
down a little bit in lhx three sides
also that happens suicides that were
early only and we're accessible like at
zero hours you see this decrease while
when they bind sites that were not
accessible what happens is that nirajan
and causes an the binding in these
places causes activations who are
increase in the in the active signal the
early only lhx three sides don't do much
nothing much happens the constant sites
they have activation is clear from here
and the late only size also because the
sides their sides to become active I'm
saying they caused it but we don't know
of course because it is just an
association that they bind them then
when they bind this happens so
right so then how does this fit how does
this fit with promoters so I show you
the promoter dynamics and I showed you
the what happens to these sites and and
so we assign these sites to their
nearest promoters within 100 kb distance
and we construct a random model of ova
associations we plot here the log fold
change of the actual associations versus
this shuffled random matrix and what you
can see is that thing promoters their
upregulated here they are enriched so
black red and red is enriched blue is
depleted so they are enriched for the
constant and late sites of LH x3 but
they are depleted yep sorry but they are
depleted from the sides that bind
accessible regions which makes sense
because we know that these sites
actually be could like go down in their
signal and we know that these sides when
when binding happens they become active
in the actual sites on the other hand
things that get repressed a very strong
depletion of our constant and late sites
but have very strong enrichment for
sites that were accessible in DB in zero
hours so this makes sense because we
know these sites are associated with the
commissioning of their of the activity
at the actual sites and they also
matched genes that become repressed and
these sites are associated with
activation of their actual sites and the
match genes that get activated and those
other genes that pretty much remain
constant have small enrichment for
basically everything or depletion for
everything so a moralist andum yeah so
this makes sense and so the next
question we can ask is um what's
happening at these sites that are
that are getting depleted I mean these
are sites that were active in yes or in
the pluripotent cells we start with and
and the binding of our factors happen
there and they went away makes sense
that these sites are where the stem cell
enhancers or the stem cell regulatory
regions and and so to check for this we
did we deduct for chip seek at these at
zero hours so at the pluripotent cells
to check whether we have enrichment of
opt for at these sites or not and what
you can see is that that's true so if
you compare your GM binding to sites
that we're accessible for the size that
will not accessible see that acht for
here is higher than here and the same
for other checks three early only you
see that acht for when they bind
accessible size decides who had opted
for enrichment while these sites did not
have opted for enrichment at least
compared to that so that means that
these sites were down by acht for one of
them employee potency Network
transcription factors and and we don't
know of course if that that's because
the sites caused the decommissioning of
of Oxford or whether box for was already
going away and these sites were just
binding to open regions that are just
open so they just bound there and this
is more of an accidental thing this
needs more experiments to determine
which scenario is the steroid one yeah
so there's a lot more to this study but
I'm not going to talk about it today
just to keep it short I'm going to make
an advertisement for another paper that
came out of Hoover's lab a year ago so
it was a collaboration with with the gym
katta naga lab at UCSD and and yeah bits
because of the discussion yesterday
about promoters enhancers which are
promoters which answers and so on this
paper is very large but relevant to this
discussion basically if you ask oops if
you ask what's up from
or what are the characteristics of a
promoter in the promoter you have these
sequence elements which we call core
promoter elements like initiate data box
and so on these things line and nucleus
on three region that can be big or small
can have variable widths and of course
on like flanking these nucleus on three
regions there's nucleosomes and these
nucleosomes have different combinations
of histone modifications that are
sitting on them you also know that most
promoters are opposed a lot of promoters
in human at least initiate transcription
in two directions for some reason and
and and one direction is the direction
where the gene is and so these
transcripts is what you eventually see
in all these RNA seek studies when you
do the poly a selected our music and
these ones are very quickly degraded so
you don't really see them in this table
RNA population so why this happens we
can talk about this however what I want
to talk about first is you have these
histone modifications you know that
transcription goes this way you have
historic asians here and you know also
there's transcription initiation going
this way so it makes sense to think okay
maybe these histone modifications are
related to transcription initiation
that's going this way and this these
histone modifications are related to
transcription initiation that goes this
way and so we did the correlations so
this yeah so I should mention the paper
this this is the paper it's mainly the
work of Scott lack adeje so here's a
post toga toga slab and when we did the
correlations of k-27 and settle on the
nuclear zones that are downstream of the
main transcription start site that's
what we call forward versus the five
prime gross leak which is a measure of
the transcription initiation rate on the
forward and the reverse side and you can
see that k 27a settle correlates with
the transcription initiation that's
on its side that doesn't correlate to
the transcription initiation that's
happening in the other direction and
vice versa yeah so if you go back to the
to this one here these histone
modifications correlate with this
transcription initiation while these
histone modifications correlate with
this initiation but not the opposite and
this makes sense so for next if you look
at are the different types of promoters
while you can see is that arm basically
you have these promoters which are which
initiate transcription in two directions
one direction makes stable transcripts
one direction makes unstable transcripts
these actually what Scott found is that
these actually come from two different
core promoters so two different sequence
elements that are sitting on on the
edges of the nucleus on free region and
reverse orientation to each other and
what Sasha at gym Carnegie's lab did is
that he actually showed that these core
promoters here can transcribe in vitro
so they are also so they are like core
promoters their promoters which
transcribes with these promoters which
are bi-directional or divergent they are
actually the result of having two
promoters each of them is unidirectional
and when you have this scenario you have
a nice unique chromatin environment
where you have this arrangement of
histone modifications downstream of this
table gene but on the other side you
have a different arrangement where you
have basically a chromatin state that
has me2 h3k4me3 h3k4 trimethylation EK
27a settle sitting on the plus one on
the i mean for this it's the +1 its
minus 1 nucleosomal yeah so it's arm so
sitting right there while this same
state here is actually occurring more
downstream and on the plus one you
please on here you have another state
which only has to be careful tri methyl
initially k-27 cell
if you have to with what we call
bi-directional promoters which is two
promoters making which is the promoter
is making two genes to stable genes it
also results from the same mechanism
where you have to call promoters and
results from and you see the same mirror
image of the chromatin environment so
it's different from here and what we
characterize is that sometimes there are
open regions where you have only one
core promoter going in the stable
direction and you don't see that I
version transcription and what these are
what we term unidirectional promoters
and for these we see some histone
modifications on the reverse side but
they are not they don't show a specific
investment for a specific chromatin
state yeah and usually these open
regions are on average smaller than this
those ones and those ones okay so though
it's who this paper is um this this is
this paper we let ourselves that January
2015 there is a review that might come
out soon yeah and yeah that's it thank
you
it's not really a motif a certain motif
that we found so we have that we had
this sequence model that you Scott
trained on one transcription initiation
ya when ya transcription start sites and
the sequencer came our model and
basically it learns the sequence of the
of the of the transcription start site
yeah I'm probably exactly promoter like
and and then you can scan any other
sites and say okay this matches these
promoters or not and that's yeah
which ones here
onkyo said oh no this is just that
drawing is just a cartoon is not so good
but here yeah that's disturb us not
being very good artists
enhancers have different chromatin state
environment so they have higher me1 than
me3 and they are so enhancers also show
this diversion transcription some
enhancers also show unidirectional
transcription there's a paper from
Christmas nut talks about this and
basically the transcribed enhancers will
have h3k27 and settle h3k4 so they will
look kinda like this except that instead
of h3k4me3 you have hv k for mono method
no more questions thanks Peter